les archives d'un massacre le 17 octobre
plusieurs dizaines de manifestants ont
trouvé la mort c'est la conclusion d'un
premier rapport révélé par le figaro
pour les associations il manque encore
plusieurs pièces dans ce dossier au
portage emmanuel les gagner et jean
bernard et hier ces sommes parqués les
bras levés derrière des barrières
métalliques
ce sont quelques uns des 25 mille
algériens français qui se sont
rassemblés rue de paris en cette soirée
du 17 octobre 61
quelques instants plus tôt à l'appel du
fln ils manifestaient pacifiquement pour
protester contre le couvre-feu qui leur
est imposé ces images ne montrent pas
mais la répression policière est très
dur voilà ce que confirme un rapport
commandé il ya six mois par le
gouvernement
d'après un bilan officiel de l'époque
cette répression aurait fait sept morts
des centaines affirmé le fln aujourd'hui
les auteurs du rapport estiment que le
nombre des victimes se chiffrent en
dizaines minorant les estimations de
certains chercheurs ce qui s'est passé
ici après s'effectuera des gens ont été
balancés dans la seine
il faut que toute la vérité soit faite
aujourd'hui c'est un début de
reconnaissance
ce n'est qu'un début de vérité j'espère
que demain on y arrivera à la vérité
totale sur cet événement leur apportons
aussi de comprendre les causes de ce
déchaînement de violence dispositif
policier déployé dans l'urgence peur des
débordements et surtout des forces de
l'ordre qui ont perdu 22 des leurs lors
d'attentats perpétrés par les
nationalistes algériens dans les mois
précédents une analyse que ne partage
pas l'un des meilleurs connaisseurs du
dossier
il ne faut pas qu'en 1998 une nouvelle
vérité qui serait une vérité officielle
viennent prendre la place d'une autre
vérité celle de 1961 qui s'est avérée
mensongère les auteurs du rapport le
reconnaissent eux mêmes c'est maintenant
aux historiens de prendre le relais mais
le travail sera difficile certaines
archives comme celle de la brigade
fluviale ont été détruites les autres